uh
we'll start the meeting do you have any
apologies for absence
um no apologies received yeah okay
item number two do we have any decorate
declarations of interest
no
okay we're going to item number three
which is minutes of last meeting to
approve his correct record
and a chair in the minutes of the
informal communities meeting held on the
27th of november
seconder
our second chair thank you
all those four
any against
and any abstentions i'll have stained
chairs i wasn't here so i can't validate
them
that's noted have passed
item number four screw review to discuss
with the healthy
lifestyles officer which i believe is
kelly matic do we have kelly massey at
all
and we do chair she didn't look in the
waiting room so i'll just i'll just
admit it okay
[Music]
hi kelly hi is it okay if i call you
kelly
yeah absolutely absolutely uh
i'm kevin tate i'm job field south and
chair of the uh
community scrutiny uh would you like an
introduction to everyone else or is it
pretty
self-explanatory all the names yeah
pretty self-explanatory thank you
okay um we'll just go on to then kelly
we've received your report
excellent um do you want to
go through it or and take questions at
the end or
absolutely is everybody managed to catch
sight of that pre the meeting
excellent so i won't go through it step
by step but i'll just pick out
the main pieces if that's all right with
everyone and
would you like to take questions after
each um
i've answered each of your questions or
do you want to wait till the end
i think after each section would be
appropriate i think uh damon if i'm
right
you able to share the report on screen
um i am yes would you like me the
initial document that you
that you sent around kelly on screen
please damon
okay sorry i just forgot to to
tell everyone i'm going to record this
if that's okay as well
so i'm just going to start recording now
my computer
[Music]
this meeting is being recorded
thanks for that damon can everybody
catch side to that
excellent right so you asked how many
people was actually in the
active and healthy lifestyles team so
the team's actually made up of seven
individuals
and so that's myself the health and
well-being development officer
we have two walking into community
offices
two sports development coaches what work
out in the local community and then we
have
um two coach core apprentices what are
currently with us
and for a 15-month period uh
whilst they're uh running through their
apprenticeship
so what i want to say to you guys is
that
um we made up for 17 members
but that all of those members are
externally funded
so um they're either externally funded
through
other partners or their salaries
are offset via income generated projects
as well
so the only cost um to the council as
you can see highlighted in red is myself
and i work 30 hours
across the service area but i think it's
also important to state that we're part
of the
wider leisure team as well so and you'll
probably be familiar with chris mills
the leisure operations manager
i sit within that team and i'm line
managed by chris
um and we link in with the leisure
facilities itself with the
exercise by referral that operates
across the three sides
um and also the swim development officer
steve birds
okay unfortunately i can't see everyone
on screen at the moment
but if anyone has any questions i don't
know if
sue can you see everyone still or not
i think i think kelly the best thing
probably is to take questions at the end
if you're okay with that
yeah absolutely fine with that that's
not a problem at all
um so you wanted to know about the team
members themselves so obviously you've
got me
so i look after the team in general so
i oversee the service area we look for
new
innovative ways of improving the health
and well
being of residents across the board and
with the main aim to reduce inactivity
levels
and we work with many um different
organizations
and to externally fund projects but i
also directly deliver a project myself
called pals
which is physical activity lifestyle
support service
so that is delivered across the ward of
clay cross
um and the idea of that is to get
somebody to become physically active but
what we do is um because we've got a lot
of inequalities in clay cross
we try and address some of those wider
inequalities what needs addressing first
before we can get people to become more
physically active
that might be support around
volunteering
and debt and finance management mental
health support
so that's my role in a in a very small
nutshell i'm sure you can appreciate
it's much wider than
probably what i've put in there in a few
sentences
so then the walking into community
offices debbie and jess
and so their job share partners
and these two elements to their project
we've got the walk-in health project
which is all about um
setting up low-level walking groups
across the whole of the district
and and it's about recruiting volunteers
and new walkers
and creating sustainability
and within those walks as well long-term
and everything we do is about creating
sustainability for the long term
because we are externally funded we
appreciate that
some of the officers might not always be
around so
at the heart of what we do is about
creating sustainability long term
the other element of their project is um
walking into communities so that's again
that's focused
in clay cross in the water plate crafts
um
and it's very much about reducing social
isolation
so the feeling of loneliness um
and creating physical activity projects
as well so reducing
um physical activity sorry reducing
inactivity levels
as you can see there they're fully
funded through
a partnership with healthy northeast
derbyshire
and through the public health funds that
we
um get through dcc
then we move on to the sports
development coaches zoe
and lauren um both team members they
work out in the local community and
they deliver a host of programmes in
community centres
and different venues and as you can see
there they deliver anything from
chair-based exercise
walk-in football walking netball etc
and but alongside of that they work in a
number of
our schools across our partnership
they're delivering quality lunchtime
provision
around pe and sport and physical
activity as well as delivering the
560 program which i touched on in the
original
report which is a 10-week healthy
lifestyle program
and then we move on to abdul and alex
and they're our coach core apprentices
so as i said before and they're with us
for a 15-month period
and they're undertaking their community
activator level 2 apprenticeship scheme
with us
and as you can possibly imagine it's
been very stock start at this moment in
time
and with all the covered restrictions so
we are potentially looking at extending
their contract with us
so it can fulfill the full
apprenticeship scheme and
get as much out of it as possible um
one of those apprentices abdul um
we set up a scheme with uh the fostering
service at
dcc and through a partnership with
active derbyshire
they put in 10k of that funding
to support a care lever they were
actually supporting a care lever as an
apprentice within that scheme as well
so i think in in terms of the setup of
the team everyone um
that's sort of a bit of an overview of
us so
is it at the point when you want to take
any questions now on that one or should
we move forward
i think if we i can't see everyone
unfortunately due to
due to being on an ipad but if we if we
wait till the end kelly if that's okay
with you and then we'll take questions
then
not a problem
the next question that the committee
asked was what resources we have to
deliver the service
um so we as i've mentioned before we're
externally funded uh
via public health and active derbyshire
and the healthy northeast partnership
personally i feel that we've got a
really good understanding of our
customer needs at a local and
national level um via the insight that
we get through our local partners
through active derby share
and through sport england um
for us we clearly focus on the outputs
and outcomes and improvements in our
service to benefit our residents as a
whole
we meet customer need as we have a very
customer outward focus view
um we've got a very effective
partnership approach
um with engaging with the public private
and the voluntary sector um and we also
very much
take on um
the support that we get from bringing um
external partners in and the value that
they can add to our agenda
um around physical activity and obesity
etc
we've got some great systems in place to
monitor and measure the efficiency and
outputs of activities
which is obviously really important to
maintain and improve
the quality of our services to our
residents
we do have very limited capacity within
the team
and however that comes with lots and
lots of productivity
um which comes from each and every
individual single team member as they've
got a real
drive to improve the services and make
them appealing
and members it sorry to our residents as
a whole
again we've got fantastic um community
providers that we link in really well
with
um such as church halls private venues
parks and open spaces and so
we do ensure that we're working and with
those partners at all times
and again our partnership approach
remains very strong
and where the team can will pull
together in other partners to support
wider agendas
again active derbyshire public health
local volunteers etc
um and as said before we get an annual
public health allocation
for health and well-being and around
physical activity
um opportunities and again there's lots
of knowledge within the team
um regarding the voluntary sector the
private and the public sector
so excuse me everyone
if we want to move on damon
thank you again i'm not gonna go
through all of these because this is
quite wordy but it was to give you an
overview of um the measures and our
outcomes and
you asked how do we know we're being
effective with our approach
so many of our projects um
they do come with their own set of
measures
however um we do set the measures
ourselves sometimes when we're looking
at different funding opportunities
through public health etc
so i've just listed a few there for you
so
we've got the walking interventions
project so as you can see
this specific um identified target
within there if you want to move down
damon for me
thank you we've obviously got the
service plan
targets and we've already touched on
that we work um
in close partnership with the leisure
team so it's a joint service plan
uh with the targets in there
down to walking for health again it just
sets out and the specific
target so that's very much about
establishing new warts
recruiting new world leaders
and and for rules we know we've been
successful
um when we've met those targets
and and there's lots of systems in place
by our partners
to achieve those targets and but i think
for me um numbers and figures are
one element of collecting data and
saying how successful that we've been
but
we do tend as a team to collect a lot of
case studies
regarding clients and customers journeys
and and we also use something that we
call reflective vlogs
um so we share those with wider partners
um to show them how successful schemes
have been in local communities
um sometimes if our main aim is to get
somebody more physically active let's
say
there's not always a kickbox what can
show that we've supported somebody with
mental health support at the same time
so we use those reflective vlogs to
share with partners
exactly what we're doing um again
important um and i'm sure some of this
is across the board as well
with other service areas but i would say
pre-covered we'll run board to hit
all of our targets um but with the
current
pandemic um we won't be
on target with a lot of our projects
because it is very much about being out
in the local community etc
you also asked what alternatives we
could do as a service area
so yeah there's lots of different things
that we could do as a service area
and again it's down to capacity at the
moment as to why we don't
do more as a service area and so if we
were to look to increase the capacity
we could offer more of our schools
across the partnership
um quality lunchtime provision and sport
but we would need to see if there was a
need there first for this sort of work
within our schools
um we could actually employ
um specific sports development leads to
look after specific
themes so currently we don't have
um anybody leading on work around
um school sports club link so we don't
have somebody looking at
sports clubs in the local community and
linking them back in with schools so for
me
that would be a great opportunity to
move forward with
and finally um sports development
officer to
support more communities of facilities
and work with other local community
sites and venues
and again our team is
very much about um reducing inactivity
levels so
especially in our more deprived
communities so
that would give a real great opportunity
to come up with
more initially sorry innovative ways
of engaging with our local communities
and venues
and i never shared with you last time
the charlie park obesity action plan
and you're a little bit concerned about
some of the time skills that have been
missed um
and what we're actually doing um to
progress this
i think it's really important to start
that that's not a document what's held
by myself
and that is a partnership approach
within the community of clay cross with
a lot of partners
so yes the obesity action plan and
a lot of the actions were due to start
back in march
2020 yeah the obvious covey pandemic
um so a lot of the actions within the
plan
are currently on hold um
we have been in discussions with the
school this week actually
to see how they'd like to progress and
as we appreciate their under
increasingly amount of pressure
and with home school learning and in
school learning for
keyword children and vulnerable children
so the school actually want to put the
um action plan on hold for the time
being
and look at picking that up again in the
new academic year from
september and i think as a as a
partnership approach
and we have to respect um
what the school would like to do with
that action plan
or um just want to reiterate that as
a as a team and as a partnership
the action plan will be in a really good
position
um to hit the ground running back
and a lot of the actions
could you just move down the document
for me damon
i think in addition um yeah just in
addition to
um it wasn't in the actual action plan
some of you may know about the pilot
scheme that took place in claytrad
and through beat the street and through
intelligent health
so basically these beat boxes scattered
around
play cross and surrounding areas and the
idea is
to improve um
people getting out walking and cycling
jogging etc we ran a four-week pilot
scheme what was all funded through sport
england
in clay cross and surrounding areas
um and we had 2170 players
engaged with that program which was
absolutely fantastic
as you can see 9700 miles
covered over that four week period we
staged
a number of community events eight
community events
we engaged with seven schools and we've
got 12 community
uh teams entered into that as well so
that that was fantastic for us during
sort of a lockdown
period of engaging with families
um with the communities as a whole
so we're hoping to build on the success
of beat the street through the obesity
group
and through other groups as well in clay
cross
and we're going to be taking a bit of a
coordinated approach to providing
something for everyone within the clay
cross area
uh i mentioned in my report last time
about
the national childhood measurement
program data
uh in that time i've recently met with
sharon put who is the service manager
for public health who looks after the
ncmp data
and i just explained our sort of
disappointment really that
because we're on the ground delivering
these sort of programs and ensuring that
they delivered to the right schools
at the right time to the right sort of
pupils that we really
needed to be privy to that data
moving forward um so i'm glad to say
that um dcc will be allowing us
that data moving forward but as of yet
i've not actually received that data
but if that's something that the
committee would like shared with them
moving forward
i'm happy to do so as soon as that data
lands with me
uh the next question was on the return
on social investment
are we better putting hard assets into
parts like football pictures
or putting resources into nutrition
so i think for me
it's equally the return that we get from
investing in parts and pitches
is really important um
however investing into a pitch or a
playing area is going to
attract clubs and individuals that are
already active
so if this is what we want to continue
to do that's absolutely fine but
we also need to decide if it's time to
start really investing
in those that aren't active and trying
to really
unpick as to why they're not active and
for me working at a very local level in
some of our most deprived communities
that's sometimes due to the wider health
inequalities what exists in somebody's
life
such as debt and finance issues mental
health
and employment and a number of others
damon do you want to just stay down
um you asked is it worth investing in
nutrition
yes but not for me it's not one or the
other i think
that both investments are equally
important
um so i don't think it should stop us
from investing elsewhere
and but as the team we've always
discussed that the 560 program
should be delivered as a key stage one
program
so we're hitting the children and the
families at a
much much younger age so we get the
families
and we get the pupils understanding what
an active lifestyle looks like so it is
about healthy eating
it is about physical activity and we're
setting those families and those
children up for life so
when it does come to the data at year 6
will really have that impact
so we will be happy to potentially look
at designing the program what's more fit
for purpose
for reception years and if that's
something we wanted to move forward with
but and i think just from my point of
view on a bit of an end note
i feel that obesity sorry damon could
you just go a
bit a little bit further back up for
thank you just stop there wonderful
and just as a bit of an end point on
this for me
um obesity needs to be looked at much
more widely
than just what somebody eats and
sort of that nutritional element of
things so
um it's about that physical activity
is about healthy eating and
but it's about improving that overall
well-being
in that family or that individual's life
and creating resilience
and improving links and to
the wider community facilities and
opportunities
so it's almost taking a whole system
approach
the obesity agenda and and
and those were just a few things that
have popped in there for good measure
and i'm sure
these other themes what could be added
um
to that system approach as well by other
service areas and departments and
partners
et cetera so we have a whirlwind tour
of my document there for everyone thank
you kelly can you
bring me back to full screen ah thank
you
thank you very much for that i'll open
it up does anyone have any
let questions see
who've i got i've got richard
and i've got roger i've got sorry
so council welton countless council hall
council hancock
council barca did you have your hand up
yeah and on my next screen i've got
councillor burkin so if we could take
them in that order if that's okay with
everyone on councillor
whom israeli sorry i missed you
uh councillor welton please
oh i was gonna go last but uh okay i
mean put on first
i think this is a step in the right i'll
send you more than welcome to go
on to well you've put me to go for
it's a step in the right direction um
i'm beginning to get a better
feel i don't think i'm completely there
and it might just be a matter of
formatting and i understand the
difficulties
when you've got you know part-time
people
people
who have other responsibilities there's
fun i mean i had this when you know with
the
homeless thing there's funding but it's
shared over different areas and people
have
shared responsibilities and they do
other things so i
i've always come to the point what i'm
trying to do is look at an orange and
apple
and say you know what actually have we
invested in this
and what how do we actually measure
whether this is the right thing
you know are we doing the right number
of things we measure the outcomes
so a positive thing of that would be the
walking for example i
i get that i understand that you know
increased couple numbers support you get
watching supervisor
it's easy um some of the other stuff
obviously is a lot softer
and more difficult and again this is
really just a general theme to pass on
on
to to the officer is it's i think this
was raised
last meeting about schools well schools
are really near the county
responsibility et cetera et cetera
should we be and again this is my
starting position where
i need you know need to be not convinced
but sort of take along the journey
what are our responsibilities in the
district and our facilities which we
know are the ledger facilities we
actually have
plus the parks and just a question about
hard versus soft
and on on the sports clubs and it all
comes down to
you know where where in where we have
right you know
limited resources where do you put that
for your return
but anyway
yeah right yeah there's just some
feedback from somewhere
yeah it sounds like we have some
feedback issues um can we just meet them
obviously except from council hall
please
yeah i think yeah should be okay now
council hall
right yeah i was just going to comment
on the beat the street
um uh uh project
it's very interesting that because i
guess one of the
important things is teamwork and getting
other people in
involved and it's it's something that i
think
would benefit not just clay cross but
many other areas as well because at the
end of the day
if you're doing something on your own um
you lose a bit of interest but when
you're doing it as a team
there's more encouragement there and
like if you're
out with friends or family or what
whatever
then it certainly makes it more
interesting
and you've got i won't say goals or
things like that but what it says
9 700 miles covered that's a phenomenal
distance
so i mean hats off to the people that
did
get involved in it um is it something
that
uh is considered
beneficial to not just clay crossbow the
whole of any ddc
thank you council kelly do you want to
yeah yeah please uh thanks for that
counselor hall
um absolutely right um it was absolutely
tremendous in terms
of the engagement that we had throughout
that program
um it very much we knew it was coming
um as a pilot scheme but then it very
much just landed with us so we did
extremely well as a
partnership again um within the local
area to
to get as much engagement as we did but
i think it just fell at the right time
for me
council hall in terms of just coming out
of
that lockdown and people not being able
to engage in their general
and community provision but again
it was free it was enjoyable it's
something you could do as a family
network
you could do with friends other family
members etc
and we did do it in a number of other
areas as well but it was more successful
for whatever reason in clay cross so it
did
encompass um grassmore
homewood and top 10 and but there was
more significant boxes putting clay
cross
and the surrounding areas um
and there isn't there is an opportunity
through
intelligent healthy lead on this project
to
have the this was a free pilot scheme
through sport england as i mentioned
earlier
but there is an opportunity to bring
beat the streets as
a much bigger program over a year period
and some of you may be familiar that um
chesterfield did a year's programme of
beat the street
um and they're still delivering on that
program now in terms of the sustain
phase which comes afterwards
and anything again it's it's about what
do we now
do with the streets it's so successful
we've got 430 followers on our facebook
page how do we
now look to further engage with those
individuals
and so again there's lots of
opportunities there for beat the streets
and kelly just done that just on that
subject sorry to jump in
what percentage of the people were
actually because i know is our scrutiny
topic we're looking at primary
school-aged children
what percentage of the beat the streets
was it families
were kids or was it just um
i wouldn't have the figures to hand on
in terms of the percentage split however
uh the majority of the individuals what
we're playing
came from the schools themselves so
we we're more in that um target of five
to 11 year olds within primary schools
and then it would have been their family
network
with them so so mainly primary school
age
pupils okay thank you council hancock i
believe you
had your hand up next thank you chair i
i can actually just add a little bit to
the question you asked there
because tucton was obviously included in
that and it was very very well received
and one one of the the big successes in
tupton we um
with some of the community groups that
put things on for young children that
weren't able to operate throughout the
lockdown
actually use beat the street as a way of
keeping those those groups going
um the children's dance troupe um was
what was one of the key ones so
it did hit the market it was supposed to
and
and it was exceptional it really was um
i mean one one thing that i mean i
totally agree with you it is a case of
looking at all aspects of obesity
and it isn't just this and and i mean
there's areas and even the more affluent
areas in the district
wingworth has some terrible poverty in
it even though overall it's seen as
being
being quite an affluent area um so i
think that that is an aspect we need to
target on and i think the partnership
arrangement needs to expand
the parishes primarily look after a lot
of park equipment they look after a lot
of
a lot of those they've got the more
direct links with the community groups
and i think actually expanding
let let parishes take on the bits that
they want to work with where they have
got the ability to influence things
and allow your budget to be focused on
on some of the stuff that parishes can't
do
um but no i i it's great work it really
is and and
as richard said it is a brilliant step
forward
and at the minute it's a lot of
fact-finding isn't it see what works and
see what needs to be built on
absolutely and thank you for that
councillor hancock
it's really positive to hear the impact
that it had in tuctan
as well as being so successful in clay
cross and some of the other small
villages around
uh but yeah i absolutely think you're
right um
allowing parishes to take on on some
work as well
um but as i say uh we take a very um
partnership view to everything that we
do do on the ground and
i'd like to say um you know 90 of the
things that we do
are very very successful based on that
partnership
which is found thank you um
i believe it's council barca next please
thanks chad i think most on it been said
really i think
from my perspective it's about the
coordination role and that and and what
we do
what's our responsibility as a district
council when you've got the health
service county council and all that
other stuff
but if we can facilitate all that and
again just to be uh
you know on the positive note the
walking fail thing at
wingfield's been it goes from strength
to strength kelly i don't know
every time i look there's there's a
different group of people but i think
before lockdown they were getting up to
over 20 turning up on a
on a tuesday uh and it's a really really
good social group as well it's it's
it's been fantastic success that has
and i'd just like to mention that i
don't know what abdul you know he
mentioned abdullah the apprentice so i
have met him because
he went through top road at kayla and
that's fantastic that he's he's
progressing with that because
uh he's not had a great starting life
has he let's put it like that
uh so that's that's good news and i did
have a go at the beat the street but i
didn't complete it so you'll have to
slap me wrist
i only did half on it and i got fed up
so there you go well we're appalled at
that councillor barker absolutely
appalled you shouldn't know about it
we've had a very well established walk
as you say from the resource center for
the last 10 years you should be getting
out with that group
and uh you should have been tapping
those beat boxes yeah don't they go too
fast for me
kelly i'll let them know
okay i think there's council burking
next is that correct
council berkeley thank you chair uh a
couple of questions kelly but certainly
before i forget myself i think you've
done very well with this
with these initiatives so
congratulations to you and your staff
excuse me not been out for me walk yet
um you mentioned earlier early on that
the uh
most of the staff i think apart from
yourself are covered by funding
partnerships uh how happy are those
bodies that are funding the staff
with the results that that you get in um
uh as a simple one i might have missed
it but what's the 560 program about
i'm not fully sure what that is um
why do you want to break or why does the
county want to pull away from the
national walking for health programs
what would be the advantage of setting
up your own arrangements
um you touched on several other things
when you're trying to get people moving
and
more active you find that there are
mental health problems
have you got links or the capacity to
to help people with those issues if and
when you identify them
um that's all i think thank you
right thank you councillor birkin um you
might have to remind me a couple of
those questions i was jotting away as
you
you were asking um but you asked about
the 560 program so you wanted to know a
little bit more about the program itself
um so historically is a
as a dcc um public health initiative
um five years ago now the funding was
pulled for that initiative
and so it's a county-wide initiative and
10-week programme within primary schools
and targeted to year four and five
pupils
um it's a ten week family lifestyles
program
so it encompasses healthy eating
and physical activity over that ten week
period
hopefully have that impact on the
national childhood measurement program
um when the pupils come to year six and
they're measured again
so that's the 560 program one full
you asked why we're looking at pulling
the walking from the national scheme
so the current national scheme um is
through the ramblers association
who um they've been very much start
start at the moment
in terms of we've secured funding for a
year
we're not really sure what's happening
after this year
etc but there is like a county
collaboration group for walking um
across the county
with all the leads from the districts
and the boroughs
and there really is a desire to
move away from the very restrictive
program that the ramblers have put in
place
and as you can imagine i think we've
been running
excuse the fun we've not been running
and walking for health for
over 12 years now across the district as
and i'm sure you can appreciate those
groups
do develop in terms of
into what we classes moving on walks
so and that's the idea really that you
start at a very low
level and we increase people's physical
activity
levels the capability levels
but it's very much frowned upon in the
current national scheme
we're only funded and ensured
to deliver low level walking so as to
say there is a real
desire across the board across garbage
share with all the leads
and to deliver the walk derbyshire model
so there has been some funding secured
and
through public health to start looking
at that model
and that work um has just been tended
out to an organization
and so hopefully um we'll be in a
position
sort of late february early march
and to understand um how
we can start delivering on a walk
derbyshire model
it will encompass a wider remit than
just
walking so it will have a low level
you're moving on walk
we'll look at jogging within that there
might be some cycling within that as
well so
it's very much taking a whole system
approach to walk in
uh councillor berkin was there a couple
of other questions as well
i think they were the only two i managed
to jot down
sorry uh yeah just a quickie you've you
mentioned that
i think all of the staff apart from
yourself are funded from
other organizations i just wondered how
happy they were with the results that
you're getting from this program
in terms of the funders how happy yeah
yeah um yeah we me as i said before
uh pre-covered we meet generally
all of our targets that are set so our
funders
are very very happy in terms of what we
achieve um
within all of our programs really we've
had no issues
in achieving our targets over the
previous years
obviously this year looks very very
different
um i guess what we do have within the
team
is some uncertainty from time to time
with only being funded for two years so
what happens next it's about creating
that sustainability etc
has that answered your question
counsellor kim
yeah that's fine thank you my final one
was about you said that
while you're while you're looking at uh
fitness and obesity you pick up that
they could be
other underlying problems and you
mentioned mental health
i just wondered once you've identified
that could be a mental health problem
with someone how do you cope with that
can you can you get links into sort of
no disrespect to you but people will be
maybe with a bit more expertise on
dealing with mental health
rather than leaving the individuals sort
of hanging in the breeze
yeah i mean that's a really great
question and i touched on that i
i sort of oversee the service area but i
actually
physically deliver on the pals program
and which is very much about taking
that um that whole approach to an
individual's life so
yes my end game is to get people more
physically active
but actually what's happening up here
what's more prevalent
in an individual's life and if
somebody's attending a food bank for
example
really if they've got the ability to go
and be physically active
in the community or within their leisure
facility
i think the answers to that is probably
no and but
mainly back to your question councillor
virkin we have a number of partners
through that scheme
within clay cross that will link him
with to provide
those services that we don't
particularly
have the expertise with um and i think
the pals around mental health um
sort of late february we should have our
own um
personal uh mental health counselling
service within pals as well
to tackle some of those issues that's
absolutely thanks very much thank you
chair
thank you i think oscar
um yeah just uh just two quick ones from
me
thank you for that kelly it's been more
than useful actually
uh i know that you've mentioned that the
um
some of the uh external
partners have got their own measures i
was just wondering
with those measures are the ones that
you know would
be expected to meet within the council
or is it just measures purely for those
because i know also with
you know you've set out some of the
measures that that we've got so it's
just wondering if there's any external
measures that we have to adhere to
um and i was just interested as well i
mean it's one that
you know i expect you know i don't
expect you to have this on
now but with the collective logs i was
quite
interested when you mentioned about
those and i was just wondering
if you'd be able to send us some
examples of those collective vlogs
because it'd be quite interesting i mean
personally for me i don't know about the
rest of the committee but just to
you know sort of have a look first and
just see what
you know the the feedback is from
individuals
thank you yeah absolutely thank you
um so in terms of external measures
um generally yes um as i've said that
the measures are
set by the funders themselves and
generally what will happen
and if we have um a long-term
um activity
um that's taking place like walking into
communities we know that that's been
funded and for four years in
total now and so what we will do is
we'll use those external measures and
we'll put those into our own service
plans so
i would say generally the internal and
the external measures are generally the
same
and in terms of the collective vlogs
absolutely we can be
sharing some of that documentation uh
with the committee or with yourself
as an individual and as i say we take a
lot from that and
it's very much about taking a behavior
change approach
um to to somebody's individual
activity and and as i say the
the wider impact that working with an
individual can have
wider than what your initial anymore
ambition was
so yeah we'd absolutely be happy to
share that with you
thank you uh council wilson
yeah thanks joe it's very very similar
very very similar to council arena's
point
which is i think when this document
comes back and i think it does need to
come back
uh uh again so that we can get you know
people like me can get a better grip on
on um
uh on on on what works what doesn't work
in the returns
do we have do we do we have from the
funders the external offenders
there's been reference to them having
measuring the success or not success and
the performance measures
are those there and can those come back
in the next revised document
in a way in which again it's building
the evidence or enabling us to assess
what what's exactly what's working or
hopefully all of it's working and
what perhaps doesn't work
so sorry counselor well and you want to
be able to see
um the actual targets and the measures
and where we're at today if we were to
come back to committees
sorry yes yes and again i think you know
um
it's because i g again i accept you know
it goes back to mosaic
about having perhaps people who do one
thing in leisure and they're doing this
as well and you've got external funding
so i'm i'm just trying to get you know
i'm sitting here going you know
where where do we put our scarce
resources should
we just do it as we is do we just
continue as we are
do we look at doing something a bit
different do we focus something
the background framework with me is
things that are our responsibility and
where we have the assets
facilities which are focused on the
leisure facilities and on the parks to
me
the rest of the stuff oil accepted is
very good so where we are getting
external funding
to me that does build the case uh
when it's for our decision making to
look at you know
what have we been doing for other people
in turn that's the way i'd look at it
and what have their what of their out
you know measures
of success the performance measures the
kpis
uh and i quite like to see that in a
simple
form that you know i can i can
understand
is that that is that as i'm explaining
it better is that
no that's absolutely fine we can
certainly put a document
well that night nigel could explain it
for me
we can certainly put a very simple
document together you lost me richard
you lost me mate
yeah we can look at those kpis and those
measures and put a document together
all i kindly ask is if that can be
post-covered or we can look at lashes
it'll look much more desirable
okay thank you well i'm just going to
flick through kelly
um unfortunately i don't have everyone
on screen so i'm just flicking through
to make sure that no one has
got their hand raised don't think they
have
there's just one final question for me
and that was on the
county obesity records i understand that
this is a
this has many areas to cover i
understand we're doing many different
things we're doing different
partnerships we're doing different
targeted approaches to various
obesity is a huge huge um
area but for me um i believe that
children are
they they're weighed measured when they
go to school
that correct and then again in year six
now
my understanding is and you can correct
me from wrong but those documents were
held by county
uh and they haven't been passed over to
us
so for me to get an understanding of
obesity within the district
i believe currently those records will
go back a few years
is that yeah yeah yeah absolutely they
have stuff for me
a true record of how obesity is changing
or for the better or or per area to per
demographic
would be seeing those records and having
them updated
i understand kobe that's been an
unavoidable problem
but certainly before kobit struck we'd
be able to see back through the years
how it's changing i'm just
i've read in year we had it in the last
meeting that it
the information of a look here there's
no school data
and because it's been held with
derbyshire county public health team is
that right
yeah that's right so you've
got no stats for recent data collection
covering 1920 today
so for me if as we're covering this
topic i think that'd be
if we could get those details and get
them all updated it would give us a good
understanding of how how everything's
changing it could be a very simple
document per
area and how the percentages are
changing that's for me
and if that would be okay
i know you you've discussed it in this
document that
you've had a meeting and the due to be
transferred over to you is that right
yeah that's correct yeah do we know
that be something that happens within
the year or is it something
absolutely yeah i did request that back
in november
um so i was told that i would be privy
to that information
come january so i'm just waiting on
that information coming back to us but i
haven't
asked for any previous years uh cancel a
tate so if you want me to sort of look
at
potentially a five year period and so we
can see if that trend has
changed i mean i put it out to the
committee but i think that would be a
a good a good death starting point i'll
just bring council hancock and i see
he's got his hand up
yeah i i agree with you chair actually i
think it there's a benefit to it and i
mean if we could even get it down to
award level or even even if it's done on
like county division so that we can
pick up on what areas we need to be
focusing more attention on
and and then we can also learn what's
going successfully in areas where it is
showing dramatic improvements because
there's a lot of data that could come
out of there that will help move your
project forward
all right i'll just flick through to see
if anyone else has their hand up
and kelly i think that's all our
questions um
if you've got anything to add feel free
if not i'm going to thank you very much
for your time
and all your hard work and i'm sure
everyone else feels the same
um you're welcome to stay for the rest
of the meeting kelly but uh
you're also welcome to leave us thank
you for your time everyone i do really
appreciate it
and your very positive comments okay
thanks everyone bye
okay
move on to item number five which is the
pers
the pest service review page eight and
that is from sam bentley and if you
remember at the last meeting we asked
her a few questions
um sam cannot be with us today but she
has replied to those
those questions which is on page 8 and i
agenda item number five
thank you dave damon
am i right in saying that you can see
everyone's screen still is that correct
i'm not if i share my screen all right
okay i think nikki sent me a message
saying you could all right not to worry
okay so that's the document does anyone
have any
comments or questions at all
sadly i can't see everyone damon's okay
to put me back to full screen again i
think everyone's got those documents
uh counselor gomez rini is indicated to
speak chair
yes councillor rini thank you chair
um yes i've had a look at these uh to be
honest uh
i think we could have done with quite a
bit more detail
um so for example with point
two um they've said that they would
suggest charges for
aborted visits um i think what we could
do with seeing with that is you know
having a look at you know
if they look to other areas and what
their charges are if they got any ideas
of any figures
um with 0.4 i would like to know
we did ask them how many uh admin hours
were used and we've not had the
answer on that one so i think we do need
to go back and just find out how many
admin hours are used
um and with 0.5
um so sorry i'm just trying to remember
the point that i was making so far
yeah so we need to know the the full
project costs so with
again we've not really had any figures
on that so
i think we do need to be going back on
that one as well and just getting a
a figure with it so yeah so very very
grateful for them
sending this but i do think that we need
quite a bit more information
okay thank you councillor madrini
you just flicked through
i just missed you you're on my first
screen
sorry i'm waving waving frantically uh
yeah i tend to agree with you there
oscar i think
er i'm just trying to remember back
though are we middle of uh
actually a total review with the pest
control services i'm just looking at one
of the answers and
future projected costs depend on the
service provision are they actually
are we in the middle of a review of pest
control and
and so do you want me to update on that
chair yes please
i'll just just wait wait
yes they have started a review and if
you remember they came back to that
meeting and gave some
you know they were at the very start and
they were just trying to find out how
much
involvement and what form the committee
wanted and
so i had a conversation earlier with the
chair
and advised that sam bentley the
environmental health
manager is coming back to the next
meeting so i can put these extra
questions to her and say you want the
detail
but then she will be back at the next
meeting hopefully with the answers to
that
and the next stage in the review because
she did express obviously some comments
on how you'd like to see the review
um proceed
okay thank you sir yeah yeah that that
makes sense
so i think so that will will be clearer
next time is basically what
does anyone else have any questions
bear with me while i flick through the
screens
no if we can just note those questions
if that's what i'm used to
thank you very much
and we move on to
item number six which is the parts and
green spaces which was to follow
has everyone seen a copy of that
nodding okay
and we should have um two officers in
now chair
steve bunt and darren mitchum
are they in the waiting room are they i
can't see
i'm just admitting them out yeah okay
thank you very much
taking our beat means we've got two
extra people
i can see steve
good afternoon steve good afternoon
everybody
steve are you okay if i introduce you
and and uh
use your your first name yeah that's
fine yeah no problem
and i believe we've got darren as well
is that correct yeah
yeah yeah darny you okay if you use your
first thing yeah no problem until thank
you
okay i'm kevin tate i'm chair of the
committee
damon would it be okay ah damon's beat
me to it he's changed your name on the
screen that's fantastic
all right we've got the
parts and green spaces report that you
sent through thank you very much
are we able to share this on screen
fantastic i know i've got a couple of
questions but um
i can't flick through it but do you want
to
uh just give us a a brief overview of
the report that was sent through
is that okay and then take some
questions towards the end
yeah that's fine and basically when we
attended scrutiny uh
at a prior uh occasion we
presented some information and scrutiny
asked to go bike
and provide a little bit more detail uh
individual sites
that the council had around the district
maintain uh a number of sites for parish
town councils etc
but what we set out here is the
broader picture in terms of the
northeast derbyshire district council
facilities
uh we've set out more detail their
actual
location uh reference
uh what uh play equipment types
are on there what the inspection and
maintenance
uh frequencies are and we've also
included things like sports pictures
everything like uh football rugby
soft sports et cetera and we have where
possible
put some information in on um
value of the equipment which has been
difficult
because some of the sites
are uh quite old and we don't we don't
have a specific
asset register uh for place sites
uh setting out the value or the
life inspection or depreciation periods
that i think summarizes the uh the
information that we sent
okay thank you
um damn is it okay to come back out the
document again if that's possible please
i know i've got a couple of questions
steve but i'll i'll open it up to
other members of the committee first see
if one else
has any questions
let me flick through and
first in yes council hancock thank you
chair
the the only thing that kind of jumps
out to myself from this report because
obviously
we've got uh initially we've got all of
the play areas
that are owned and maintained by north
east then we've got the
the shared ones that include the parish
ones
when we're getting onto the playing
fields it's much more limited because
obviously northeast do the grounds
maintenance on a lot of
parish sites so this this the the the
actual
like football pictures etc is is
considerably shorter of what what the
reality
is um so it kind of would have been nice
to have that extra information in there
so we got a better overview of the whole
district because
that's really deceptive it looks like we
we're a lot more inferior than we are in
terms of what we're providing across the
district
just on that council hancock uh the
previous scrutiny
we did provide a uh document
which uh planners uh pulled together and
it gave the
uh a broader picture of the entire
district whether it be district council
parish town or in private uh
tenure and we're asked to go back and
provide a more concise picture
on uh the district council
uh facilities uh so that that this
information presented today
reflects that uh more of a detailed look
at the district
yeah it's they sorry i would i would it
could be just me and my expectations i i
would
you know like the middle section of the
report where you've highlighted in two
colors according to
which is which that that to me would
have been a more logical
logical way of presenting that because
then we've kind of got
got the whole picture and we can
identify rather than rather than
this which is a little bit more hit and
miss to be honest
okay thank you if i can come in there i
think what we asked for at the last
meeting was to look at all the sites
which we control
as north east derbyshire so we wanted
we wanted to have a look at every single
play area
that was maintained and owned by north
east derbyshire and all the other sites
which were
maintained and owned by north east
armstrong
if i can bring up today a little bit
there
i've i don't see if there's any other
hands up i've got a couple of questions
steve if you don't mind
do you know the play value score how's
that calculated
you want do you want to pick that one up
darren uh well there's several indices
uh
national indices that uh we utilize um
the play value one on this and the the
shown on there is is utilized by our
independent and playground inspector
um once a year we have all playgrounds
in the district independently inspected
and as part of that inspection process
we ask them to to put a play value on
that on the particular side
um i don't without looking at the
documents
that we've got i can't remember which
indices he uses
um on that but i can i can double check
while we're while we're in
uh on screen now while we're discussing
that matter
the only question i have regarding that
is is this score out of 100 or is it out
of 50 or
it varies because what you'll do what
the what they do is they take in
the certain points criteria regarding
the location of the site the actual
value of the
equipment itself and
the environment and the the
well it's probably easier for me to
describe it by looking at the actual
document
itself and talking you through it if i
could just put that on screen for myself
absolutely
that's if damon could help us there at
all that'd be great
just bear with me
no sorry it's not that document it's a
document in
my folder it's on my pc sorry
with regards to the scoring then darren
does it does it work from zero to
zero up or does it work from 100 down
i'm trying to be cool sorry counselor um
we can come back to it down if it's yeah
i'll go well
well it's np mpfa um
indices that we use that's the national
plan
that's the national plainfield
association so what you what they'll do
is the site features so then you've got
you've got like
paths lighting fencing self-closing
gates
and they are score levels in in that so
you could
it could be the scope would be between
one and three
for the type of pathway that's in there
so you might score a three where it's
it's a nice tarmac footpath that's uh
uneven so
for disabilities etc or you could score
a one where it's just a stone footpath
leading into the actual park
then there's there's scoring for
lighting
signage um shelters layout
visual appearance cycle racks signage
that amount that totals up to a score
for just your site features then you've
got your equipment features
which then they look at balancing
jumping climbing agility
all in viewing platforms ball game areas
wheel play
um and that that that totals a
score and they have play cooperation
which is
interaction with children so the
children interacting
in a certain people make their own play
value
uh water play social play and then if
there's any
educational any special needs equipment
graphics on grounds any items that have
got sound
and anything that's got a play challenge
i don't know exactly what that play
challenge would be
um but that's all amalgamated up and
what you get is a total score at the end
um
which um from the the value of these
then
we have like a breakdown so you have
sites with naught and 14.
15 to 17 18 to 34
and then sites over 35 are clusters as a
good
quality playground
so anything under 35 is it depends on
what it is it depends on you could have
leaps neaps and leaps so which are
you've got your local area playground
your neighborhood playground
so normally neighborhood playgrounds are
very
should i say low scoring anyway because
the local
sites small little pocket parks within a
smaller clouds in the state
where yeah your leaps and you need your
bit your bigger playgrounds which
serve a wider should i say attractive
uh sort of say wider neighborhoods
to a bigger site like you like your
cliff parks in dromfield your charlie
parks
where more people they're they're gonna
score higher because
you're going to have more should say
more of a suitable site to put various
different types of play equipment
from age ranging from your young young
people
sorry for young children to sit so
obviously your older children
where family you can take a family to to
the site
and obviously that is they can control
the older kids can go off while they
control the younger kids on the smaller
playgrounds
um you locally your little neighborhood
playgrounds tend to be for the younger
age range
which don't have probably a good play
value score
okay thank you very much so councillor
barker
and councillor burkins let me quickly
flick through
if i can bring castle barker in first
time cheers
okay i mean we're going to get some
ben's emptied steve sat there
sorry i know i know you've had it rough
mate okay
i think that scoring thing's fairly
self-evident the the more equipment
you've got the bigger the score and all
that sort of stuff
uh i'm just trying to and i know i keep
asking this one
kevin at last meeting i think
you could stand corrected on it but the
reason what we we're trying to do
are we gay you know on our facilities
our parks at the district council own
and we've got the equipment are we
making the best use of them
themselves i think that's what we're
trying to get at to get people
using play equipment you know physical
activity things
uh am i right kevin that that's what
ultimately we're trying to get at
it's difficult if we don't own the site
if it's a parish council one because
you know we might maintain it and
inspect it
but it ultimately is the parish council
that puts the equipment on
are we getting are we using these parts
uh to get people active in the best as
we can is what i'm
i think we're trying to get out kevin
didn't it
yeah the reason why i wanted to look at
all the parks is because for
children of school age which we're
having a look at
a good park nearby is always going to be
a bonus to getting them out and more
active
so the idea behind looking at the parks
was to see which parks we have
which age groups to cater for the
condition of the park
and do we have any do we invest in the
parks
have we spent any money in them have we
in the la to make sure they're
maintained and safe
and then are we looking forward are we
are we
going to be maintaining them are we
going to be upgrading them
all along those sorts of lines so that's
why this report's in there
and the reason it's just any ddc is
because
towns and parishes they're responsible
for theirs
but as a scrutiny committee we've got to
look at what we're doing at northeast
derbyshire
so that's the reason for it for being in
there if that answers your question
council barker
thank you i know i've got council birkin
and then council welton
thank you chair um
the detail that steve's just learned
about those national
plainfield association scores seems to
me
too much detail i can't see because of
all the variations i think
i've written down about half a dozen and
i think there are a few more
[Music]
categories and i'm i'm
just wondering if you can score three in
one but not in another
and somebody else goes none in the first
one and three and the other are they as
good as each other or
or which which will be best which would
be giving the best service
as as councillor barker and new chair
have just said
uh which have we um invested in which we
need to invest in
it sounded to be honest off to my ears
much too complicated to really be of any
value
thank you council becky i know council
wilson your johanna
uh yeah just to agree with councillor
birkin and go back to remarks of
councillor barker and again my own you
know sort of try to
make make sense of everything there is a
bit too much detail in that
it's about focus focus on obesity
amongst children
and on what is actually under our
control and responsibility
that's tracking vacuum which to me are
the leisure facilities and the parks are
we making the best use of them can we
encourage them
where should we put it be putting our
resources so
that that to me is what you know what i
think we sort of
we're trying to evaluate
thank you chad um yes i was just having
a look at the
document um so it was sorry if you just
bear with me here we go
uh it's the costing
i'm just trying to tell you which one it
is just so you know what i'm
referring to um
so it's the cost in document anyway so
it's basically it's it's
got the what we've spent um
so i can see that we've got some
from 2016. and i was just wondering
because looking at what we've spent with
the parks i can see that we've got some
from
so 20th of september 2016 and then we've
got
um campaign drive 2019 and then
there's nothing until the 22nd of
december 2020
and i mean i suppose really the question
that i'm asking is
have we not spent anything you know if
we only had one expenditure on the parks
you know that being 2019 between uh
2016 and then december 2020
i don't know if steve or darren wants to
answer that one
yeah just picking up uh capra gomez's
comments on spending particular capital
spend
uh and they've been earlier comments
about uh
player refurbishment we don't we don't
have
a capital replacement problem like for
instance we would have with vehicles
a bin wagon we biked for seven years etc
and that's purely utilization we don't
have
uh such a planner program
for children's play areas that
we've got a rolling program that we
replace
so many or refurbished so many say two
or three a year or
something like that and it tends to be
led uh i demand that
we may have some form of complaints or
local
uh lobbying or for instance through
section 106 arrangements where
an estate's built they propose
a small play area with just a seat a bin
and a couple of small insignificant
items and equipment that's got little to
no value
uh so we we have a commuted summer
uh section 106 arrangement
whereby we can then look at investing
and refurbishing already established
play areas
one one of the issues we have with play
areas is
we have new estates and we we have uh
play areas that go on them and then the
people that live at the side of them
don't want them because they can be
having anti-social behavior
and then we have the argument that uh
the the parks that are in park so for
instance
drumfield big uh cliff park etc ideal
for having a multiple
range of equipment in it and a lot of
people don't want to go there because
it's inconvenient or they're not
comfortable sending the kids there on
their own so you've got these competing
view on play areas about suitability
suitability and location so we've tended
to
try and move away from having lots of
little play areas
taking the section 106 monies and
letting that influence refurbishing
either district council players and
parish council players for that fight
in terms of the mpa score if i could
just comment on uh
councillor berkey
is correct and the score
is meaninglessness to local
need so for instance we're just doing a
piece of consultation
on a potential refurbishing a play area
and we go
to the local uh groups total parents
groups schools etc
and ask them for their views on what
they would like so if they don't want a
bike rack
and that doesn't pop up we don't put a
bike rack in
we don't get a point for a bike rack on
the
uh equipment type in the score so
uh it's got its value
but then it is a negative side of it so
the player
the nfpa play score rating
uh yeah uh in some
instances it's got value to it and in
some others
it's totally meaningless
you steve uh i know i've got council
hancock and then council welton did
anyone else have their hands up
and then council gomez rooney if i bring
castle hancock in first place
thank you chair yeah i mean it's just to
really pick up on what steve's saying
there because
as you go through that list obviously
that there's
there's some diversity in where they are
but some of these are kind of like
really tiny
play areas in the middle of housing
estates and of course the
the big issue that you find with a lot
i'm familiar with several of these
they're built with the estate a family
moves in around them
because when they move in their young
children but then the families don't
move the children grow up so you've got
the same people in these houses for 20
to 30 years
they fall out of any requirement because
other people in the area don't even know
they exist because they're so tiny and
tucked away
and and of course the children that were
toddlers at the time they move in
are away at university and then starting
families of their own elsewhere so that
there is kind of
limited shelf life on some on some of
these when they're going in certainly
on new developments i think and i i mean
the the diversity of what we've got
there yeah but
and you look at these and some of them
like 20 30 and 30 years old but it's
it's like that there probably isn't a
lot of value
in in those smaller pocket ones
council welton yeah i think there is
maybe a very focused
question uh that we are able to ask is
should there be a capital replacement
program
across the uh across the district and
how is that going to be assessed and
again that feeds into the questions
about
do you go for where there are economies
of scale or science with the larger
parks or do you distribute things
uh throughout so i think yeah that that
is it that is a
fair question and conclusion i think
perhaps we we can discuss
section 106 i mean again it will be a
move again
106 money is a completely different
topic as we know and i and that would be
i think
quite a rational basis for um
this scrutiny and the topic that we that
we have to ask that question
thank you councillor welton thanks for
going training
thank you uh sorry steve i'm picking
your brains here
um that's fine it's just to sort of go
back to the
the my original question so yes i mean
based on i
i totally get what you're saying with
the answer um
so would it i mean i was having a look
so we we do the inspections so looking
at these you know
with all of us the the monthly um
so if it is a case you know that we've
got a park that is
you know it's quite old and the
equipment might not be up standard etc
um so i'm assuming obviously after the
inspection that will then go back to the
council
i mean would we obviously then you know
do decides it is
you know is the demand for this have we
had any inquiries come in if the answer
is no
then you know we'll we'll you know just
leave that for now
um and with the so with the equipment
then so this
this quite big spend on the 22nd of
december
was was this one do we know was it a new
park is it
section 106 that would have come in
want to comment on that darren please
turn your mic on darren you're on mute
i'm afraid
that's you okay uh yeah counselling um
right oscar
i'm sorry gomez reenact um
which part which part was it in
particular we're commenting on
well to be honest i mean the so the
first question about
obviously with the spending on the parks
and the inspections so that's just
you know all parts in general you know
we'll see if we see that the
in need of new equipment etc um and then
it was so it's on the costing so it's
the 22nd of december
um so there's quite a quite a lot
of money spent there um so i mean to i
mean to be honest the
so the the answer that i'm wanting is is
basically why
since 2016 and then you know up to 2020
you know also we had the one spend on
champion drive and then obviously we've
had this then
a very big spend so but quite a large
gap of
you know no spending bar one but then
obviously there's been these
you know quite a substantial amount of
money spent on the 22nd
right yeah the expenditure on the
the two players was 16 106 money which
was granted to the council
um there wasn't any other local area
playgrounds and it wasn't suitable in
where they're proposing it on the
development so we utilize the money to
improve our
existing sites um
regarding inspections obviously as our
teams go out we'll we'll we
if there is majority of the equipment is
that isn't sound structural it's
probably just getting aged and outdated
and we're finding that out from a recent
consultation we're undertaking now
from which we are looking at a
playground in dromfield
upgrading um
[Music]
as the service and the inspection
process
the most of the wearing parts to change
the bearings we can replace
and we are replacing them and that's why
the playground will continue to be
utilized in that respect it's probably
the age of um becomes unappealing for
for children when there's more modern
sites out there and when children see
them they want
obviously that kind of equipment on the
same sites and
it's like anything fashion things evolve
and playground and equipment evolves and
people
and children want to play on that
different type of replay equipment
and yes a lot of our sites are from 106
agreements or planning gain where
they've built that development
um and that's why there's not been a lot
of investment in playgrounds as you can
see
unless it's been a new site like clay
cross joey was a development
um extol player it was a development i
was looking at the latest one stubbly
place we actually
got some grant funding for that one in
drumfield
campion drive was 106 funding
so all the latest ones i've even been
grant funding that we've obtained from
big lottery
or section 106 funding
okay thank you
i think there's no more hands being
raised i think the question for me is um
what are the condition of these parks
there's no
i know you've sent documents through but
there's no there's no record of
what condition they currently are in i
know you say and just one other thing
is it our team internally that inspects
the park
because i know uh i know a minute ago it
was an external
inspection is it an internal or
yeah i'm sorry yeah it is an internal
inspection we do 12 monthly inspections
engineering
inspections um but we also have
employ an independent inspection once a
year that's divert
that's to qualify what we're doing and
for our insurance purposes as well
um and they will provide a report and
it's normally very similar to our report
anyway on what we've found
in conditions um they would probably do
a bit more in depth in in actual
the structural integrity of the
equipment
where we look at the nuts and bolts of
of the of the equipment
in relation to moving parts and where
a lot of the wear wearing parts like
your bushes your bearings
your swing chains aaron do you want to
touch on rosper the
what the our inspectors are uh trained
and qualified
yeah i mean all our inspectors are
trained up to uh our people there's a
playground standard rpi
too which uh is for our inspectors
and we are we are all trained up to that
standard
okay fantastic and does anyone else have
any other questions
i think for me it would be uh just
just asking for a little bit more
information on the shelf life of our
parks i know we've got no capital
expenditure
sorry about that but then
certainly to look towards the future how
long how long have we
are we able to maintain these parts
before they become
unmaintainable so we're looking at five
years ten years
so that'll be something i've been
looking for information on
i know we've had this scoring criteria
etcetera but
in terms of shelf life because at some
point
there will be a community group or there
will be there will be a need to replace
a park and that that could be a large
expenditure for the council
if we're not maintaining i know we're
maintaining but if we're not looking
towards that
then we're going to start losing parks
if i if i can pick up on that to counter
tape yes sorry i can't see
sorry steve i can't see you all the time
so i've got a split screen
all right sorry i'm sorry get a bit
closer scare you
um yeah in terms of the play areas what
the shelf life is
a lot of it really uh depends on the
nature of the equipment so
if we have for instance uh a pair of
swings
we've probably got swings out there uh
they all wick these swings that are
probably 40
30 40 years old and where the change
where we can put new chains on we can
put new seats on etc
same with some of the fixed apparatus
here your multi
units where you climb on and the slides
are done
they can last for quite some
considerable years
i think the thing that and we can keep
maintaining them and repairing them etc
fixing the moving parts the thing where
it becomes
as darren touched on because of their
age
uh they become they can become
unappealing
so it retracts from
uh young children kids etc wanting to
use them so
so from a player value point of view uh
it is much reduced uh so
that's why that but there is no
we have got no uh
defined shelf life or capital program
that says
that every year if we've got 60 play
areas
we are going to refurbish uh five of
them every year
this is the capital budget and we've
also got the section one
uh or six monies that we anticipate it's
a very difficult one and it's it's
forever like council anchor but earlier
about
the little small space is on the new
developments that the
kids grow up and move on and they've got
low value
another thing to remember is that some
of those spaces are low value
they are generally constructed on land
that cannot be built on
so where a sewer or an easement of some
sort
goes through it so the land itself has
got no real value to it
and and all they become is uh green
deserts on housing
and i was in the states okay thank you
uh
i don't know who was first with
councillor birkin and council going to
training
good for you council burkin thank you
chair just just following up on what you
said
and steve's maybe just half answered
what i was asked what i was going to ask
so
is it not possible or is it not policy
to put any uh money aside each year for
a rainy day that as you were just
suggesting steve um
after the 60 sites are we going to have
to replace one of them every
two years five years already is there no
opportunity
for that at all i don't i don't think
there's
it lacks the opportunity there's always
opportunity there
the question is is as members uh is that
is that something which you or as a
scrutiny
yeah what to put forward to further
explore and that's something that's
gonna have to be
uh looked at in terms of whether or not
we have a specific element of the
capital programme uh that affords
some type of resource etc and that's
something we'd have to
have the discussions with our finance
colleagues and
[Music]
then whether or not it fits in with the
wider finances of the council
but that that's a question at the end of
the day uh
scrutiny that's where you're going to uh
possibly make a recommendation to or to
not
from a service point of view uh
yes it would it would be nice to have
uh some form of guaranteed
resource yeah that enabled us
to uh to have a plan structured approach
to refurbishing or providing uh play
equipment
and have a better standard than what we
do currently okay thank you i'll
bring council gourmets and castle welton
in
it's just touching on that i'd like to i
know we've
not been in previously steve but we're
potentially going to be having a report
from the district about obesity in
younger children
and you touched on areas not being so
appealing
in those areas where we've got the
highest of easter i'd like to see them
have the most appealing parks
so that the kids can get out and play
and they're not
40 i know i understand that it could be
40 year old swings and it could be
perfect
but my my understanding is that if we
want to get kids out
and playing and exercising it's got to
be in the areas with the highest obesity
they've got to have the nicer more
appealing parks
i'll bring council gomez in thank you
yeah i mean it was
just a uh more of a comment really which
gels into what you've just said sharon
and what councillor birkin was asking i
am wondering that's it obviously with us
not having a capital program you know it
doesn't seem as though we
we really have got the the funds for
these parts and obviously
you know as you've said they will age
and they'll become unappealing and
people
you know naturally they will stop using
them and and i think probably one thing
that
might you know sort of fall victim to is
mistakenly thinking that people aren't
bothered and there's not a demand for
the parks whereas actually if it was a
case that
you know we'd updated them and freshen
them up then families might be more
you know inclined to be going and taking
the kids etc
so i i think personally for me i think
we
we probably ought to really be you know
thinking about the funding side of it
yes council welcome yeah just to repeat
what i said earlier should we have a
capital replacement program on what
basis that should be
looking at again fashion changing the
fashion takes us slightly out of the
remit of looking at
obesity in young children but in terms
of going to the
to talk to the finance department they
will need the information first so again
should we be looking at very top line
what would be a capital
capital replacement program again and
what should that be focus and watch the
basis again
should it just be on the bigger parks
etc so yeah
thank you councillor welton
yes council hall i see you have your
hand up yeah
thank you when steve talked about some
of the equipment being
40 years old also excuse me sorry
and that some of the equipment like the
wick steeds
equipment is 40 years old i i guess
like even refurbing it would be
sufficient because it's made to such a
high
standard or quality i can't see
like and the equipment that it is like
swings and slides which tend to be wick
steed equipment
whether you take the full slide or
swings out and replace it they're going
to be virtually identical so i'm sure
there'd be some cost saving leaving
the original frames in and either
repainting them or
what whatever you have to do to it i i
guess that's something that would work
in our favor leaving
the original equipment there
yes steve i see you for you yeah i mean
what council said
is is only correct yeah it was
substantially
uh built equipment the issue with it was
some of the old for instance wig steve
swings
they are large swings they are large
hays and
the issue is not necessarily the the
equipment cost itself
it's the safest surfacing below it so
because of the size of them
and the size of the bays and this safe
a safe uh play space around it we have
to leave a
zone for kids to be able to walk past
strings as they're swinging
the safer surface itself is massively
expensive
so a very old large set of swings
demands
quite a several thousand pounds worth of
safety surfacing
and because of the size of them and the
bays and the trajectory on what they
swing through
we have to leave wider space which
limits and constrains
putting other equipment in so when we
are refurbing
uh equipment uh a site sorry with that
type of equipment um
we generally find it's not only more
cost effective
but we can we can maximize
the the available space to maximize the
player value
that we're going to replace the
equipment with so
it's all manners of dynamics and
influences that
influence that okay i think that's right
darren what'd you say
darren your microsoft unfortunately
it happens to everyone yeah sorry but
i'm not used to zooming
yeah no that's great steve yeah he's
definitely um
without incidences uh like i said where
even the larger weak state swings we've
had to remove
what the standards were many years ago
used to have three swings in a bay
now with them to put two swings in the
bay and sometimes
unfortunately it does become economical
like steve said
area surfacing increases and it becomes
more of a
like a constraint to what you can put in
them site so
we do replace them with smaller swings
now
that's generally why you'll find that on
the housing estates on the small side
a developer when they're proposing
things yeah they will put
a little put one uh a one-two base set
of swings
and they'll put the little springy
rockers in so they're low cost
and they demand low areas of safety
surfacing and that's where the
predominant cost is
on the safety side okay thank you
has anyone else got their hand up yes
councillor barker
just to sort of i'm sure you'll do it
anyway
but if we're linking this into the the
review about obesity and that
then then this is going forward we can
link this as a as
a possible recommendation about the
capital program or wherever because
it's linking it in and making it cost
effective and why are we doing it and
all that sort
of it's it's where it's circling it and
uh it's i think it's just where we go
next week that's all i'm trying to
to make clear in me at a moment
yes thank you council black i mean for
me it's all about
i don't know stephen and darren touched
on it it's about desirability we could
have
we've got we've got 26 parks we expect
to maintain 26 and we own 26
but we could have i don't know four or
five in clay cross
very undesirable kids aren't going to
them they've fallen into disrepair we're
spending a lot of money repairing them
fixing them they're vandalized and
so you change the appeal of a park you
then change
you might change the opinions of the
kids within the park and all of a sudden
it's not costing as much to repair
there's no vandalism
and if that's an area of high obesity
when they're increasing
kids going out and playing and so and
that can be linked into
healthy nauseous dog show stuff so
i'd like to see a list of all the
starting with the least desirable park
in which area it was and if we can link
that into
a percentage of obese children with
within the target group that we're
looking at
then we can maybe do something about it
and introduce a capital program
to bring the parks up to standard
i see a lot of people nodding maybe not
not everyone but
that that would be something i would be
looking at sorry darren
sorry steve sorry i didn't see your hand
up now
just picking up on what you said there
is if we've got for instance five parks
in clay cross the question is do you
want five parts in clay cross
you do you step back from the little
small spaces as the counter line can't
touch done yet
and actually concentrate the investment
and a wider
range of uh play value equipment target
on on certain strategic sites in
particular sites
where you might have already recreation
facilities such as
uh football crickey so princess charlie
park yeah
concentrating uh a
a better place based with better value
yeah
similar to like in drumfield now we've
got cliff park
so instead having all these little sites
step back from those
and and have uh central
parks in in key areas where you're
investing
okay thank you steven see you've got
your hand up castle hancock
thank you chair yeah i i mean i actually
think this the ideal suggestion is is a
balance between what yourself and steve
steve are picking up on here because one
of the biggest downfalls that we have
with with these smaller parks apart from
the fact that children grow up
you also end up with with a park where
you've got
equipment for seven and under then
obviously that doesn't if you've got a
child that's eight or nine or one that's
five or six which a lot of families are
in that position
they're too young to be going to these
places on their own
you're not catering for the needs of the
other child so so you are better having
an all-encompassing one and maximizing
your larger spaces
and making those suitable for whole
families and and almost
detract from having these these that are
just age focused
at a particular group um because they're
not meeting the needs of the community
and that that's ultimately what he
should be doing
okay thank you much castle hancock
if no one else has any comments or
questions i think we'll uh
i'll thank both darren and steve very
much for the time
it's very much appreciated thank you for
your hard work in the report
and you're welcome to stay but you're
also welcome to go
now i'm going to taking councilor
barker's comments i'm going to go and
empty some bins
of
thank you thank you
if we can move on then to ant-mate which
is the scrutiny work program pages 9-13
anyone have any comments or
questions
cheers counselor gomerini oh
sorry i'll i'll let suga first oh sorry
sorry counselor yeah no i was just going
to sound the healthy partnership working
this is the
annual report that you get from that um
that officer but of course you she may
have something she can add into this
review
because obviously she does work with the
healthy partnership
so it may be worth bearing that in mind
when you're receiving her report
okay thank you sir sorry sir i couldn't
see you because you're on the other
screen
hide it away yeah
i was just purely going to make a
comment i know that
when when we looked at it it's quite
busy and i was just going to say i don't
know
i mean whether we think that that we're
going to be okay with the
with march and may or i don't know our
people mark field you know if we put
another one in in between i just don't
know whether we were going to be
spreading ourselves
i think sue's the best one to answer
that you soon
normally would be all right with these
meetings if if at the next meeting we
need another one we could always
yeah that might be the way to go chair
to have your next meeting
um you've asked for some information
back from
uh stephen down which obviously i'll
bring
um you have got on um pest service
review on your next
one if you still want to proceed with
that of course you could
you could go with all that and if you
don't have enough time
put an extra one in or of course you
could
uh leave that um till your last meeting
it's really your choice chair i mean i
think it's probably best to do the next
meeting then decide
you know whether you need need depending
on the evidence that you've made
um but certainly at the next meeting
that's where you do to triangulate all
this evidence you've gathered
so it's a decision you'll need to take
whether you've heard enough
for you then to start that triangulation
program
okay thank you soon
okay if there's no comments or questions
i'll move on to
additional urgent items
and if nobody has any
we'll go on to date and time and next
meeting it is due to be on friday the
5th of march
and with that in mind i believe sam
doesn't work on a friday
so it may be changed to a thursday if
that's okay with everyone
we will yeah when i can't make friday's
kevin so if it's a friday
just take my apologies just just one of
the questions just going back
i'm still a bit as i said i'm still a
bit fuzzy
on the yeah trying to get my grip around
you know the the presentation on the
the healthy lifestyle thing i'm still a
bit fuzzy on that so
i don't know if we are moving to
triangulation a decision are we moving
on the basis of just those bits and bobs
she's going to add or
or or is that going to be re-jigged into
into a new you know into an improved
format
uh i believe sue has made some notes on
that item
and we've all asked for various
different pieces for it
so that'll come out before the next
meeting uh
and we can make a decision from there
yeah that's what i was going to say
chair i mean obviously i'll chase up all
these
items and we'll see what we get back and
we'll try and get it out to the
committee
in advance and then we can perhaps come
to some decision whether
you have enough um i mean i did advise
the chair earlier
that if needs be obviously it could be
an extra meeting
or you could even um defer your
triangulation to that last meeting
but then you'd have to take a delegated
decision to approve your report
via email and which is not ideal but we
could do that at a push
so it's entirely up to the committee
next next meeting
okay so that decisions to be made at the
next meeting is that correct
it isn't it isn't chair because of
course um i'll send you this information
out
and if you're going to triangulate at
the next meeting i probably would do
your resume of a lot of the information
that you've heard so i'd want to put
that on the agenda so you could have a
look at that in advance
okay right
so we'll leave it as is
and wait to see what we get back for the
next meeting
and it's due to be on the 5th of march
but it will probably be if we want to
have
um if we want to have kelly massey back
it may necessarily it won't be on a
friday yeah if you need kelly massey i
mean
if i'll ask them for the information
asap
then it gives the committee perhaps
chance to um
take a decision on whether they've got
enough and either through you chair or
me
um let me know what your thoughts are
whether whether you think you've got
enough in advance of the meeting then we
can decide
where we go from there okay no problem
is everyone happy with that
um check everyone's not in yeah
okay uh i'd like to thank everyone for
the time
uh and now declare the meeting closed
thank you very much
you